guillon sera un rendez vous galant
ils oublient verrouiller les portières
de son auto à la fin de la soirée il
retourne à son véhicule et découvre sur
son siège
un constat d'infraction 63 dollars
pourquoi parce qu'au québec il est
interdit de laisser son véhicule sans
surveillance à moins d'avoir verrouillé
les portières
sinon cela encourage le vol et le
vandalisme guillon n'est pas une seule à
avoir payé la note
à montréal seulement plus de 4300
conducteurs ont reçu un constat
d'infraction pour la même raison en 2017
mais les autres provinces n'appliquent
pas ces règles par exemple à churchill
au manitoba des résidents sont même
encouragés à laisser leurs portières
déverrouillées
parce que leurs voitures sont un refuge
idéal contre les ours polaires qui
pourrait éroder
le fin mot de l'histoire à moins de
vivre avec les ours polaires verrouillé
dans vos portières